[Music]
alright went talk to Jay Sekulow the
president's attorney the chief counsel
for the American senator of law and
justice besides making a call a
president to send American troops into
harm's way this is now the most
important decision a sitting president
can make but now the second time in less
than two years president Trump has
selected a nominee for the US Supreme
Court and just moments ago the president
picked judge Brett Kavanaugh to replace
the outgoing Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy of course this was not a
surprise in an unprecedented move Judge
Cavanaugh was selected from a previously
released list of 25 originalist justices
making this just one more example of how
this president is the most transparent
president in history and also keeping a
clear promise to the American people now
clearly this was not a decision that the
president took lightly now President
Trump in many ways there's political
aspects to this and he had to threat a
political needle and by the way he has
to think about senators like Collins and
Murkowski and then on the other side
senator Ted Cruz of Texas Rand Paul of
Kentucky
in other words picked a judge with a
very narrow margin of the US Senate who
could also successfully maneuver through
a confirmation hearing and garner the
votes from a majority of senators
without a doubt justice Cavanaugh is an
extremely qualified candidate educated
at Yale Cavanaugh clerked under Justice
Anthony Kennedy just like Neal Gorsuch
in the 1990s he served as an associate
counsel for Ken Starr that of course
during the investigation into then
President Bill Clinton during that time
it was interesting Cavanaugh did push a
controversial opinion that Bill Clinton
had in fact obstructed justice by
sometimes making false public statements
were sending surrogates out to do such
about Starr's investigation judge
Kavanagh in a very interesting piece
that he talked about in 2009 he did
change course and he publicly changed
his opinion on the issue of obstruction
was a very powerful article that was in
the Minnesota Law Review we'll go over
that in more detail in 2006 he was
appointed by George W Bush to serve on
the US Court of Appeals for the DC
Circuit where he amassed a lengthy
record of very key important decisions
he's considered one of the most
important courts
the land including multiple opinions
against the overreach of then President
Obama's EPA other opinions that in fact
bolstered our Second Amendment rights
one point of concern was judge
Cavanaugh's mix track record on one
issue obamacare but after years on the
DC Court of Appeals
what is his originalist and
constitutionalist track record is fairly
extensive and fairly robust and by the
way to all you never Trump is out there
all across America you tried so hard to
prevent a trump presidency
are you happy tonight at all can you
admit you were wrong at all are you
happy about let's see tax cuts promises
made promises kept are you happy that
this was not Hillary Clinton tonight
appointing a judicial activist a
left-wing activist to the Supreme Court
are you happy you don't have to radical
judges on the Supreme Court would you
rather have Hillary Rodham Clinton
making this election tonight now in
moments we're going to give more
analysis of Judge Cavanaugh it is also
important to review the extreme measures
that the left in America will take in
order to bond line this merge destroy
the reputation of Judge Cavanaugh and
also his family that you saw tonight
it's a story as old as time for decades
every single solitary nomination to the
US Supreme Court by a Republican
president has bet been met with the same
destructive tactics from the Democratic
Party now regardless of who was
nominated regardless of what their
qualifications regardless of their track
record even and adherence to the US
Constitution the foundation of our laws
in this of course Republic that we live
in a constitutional republic you have
the left you have Democrats and their
friends in the media that their echo
chamber always conducting what is a
malicious campaign to impugn the
character of good people the track
record of good people frankly anybody
that president Trump would have
nominated to the Supreme Court the
language gets down right apocalyptic and
this time is no different let's just go
back let's take a look at how the left
was treating president Trump's
nomination before the announcement
tonight it is really bordering on
insanity what's this
you just have to remember how extensive
the conservative agenda is here for for
the Supreme Court it's not just rolling
back abortion rights it's not just
rolling back gay rights it's not just
eliminating affirmative action it's not
just expanding the death penalty I've
never recall a previous president
outsourcing at least the initial
selection process to an outside interest
group the way that this president has to
the Federalist Society a woman's freedom
to make sensitive health care decisions
hang in the balance with this nominee it
is near impossible to imagine that
President Trump would select a nominee
who is in hostile to our health care law
and health care for millions and
millions and millions of Americans who
is in hostile to a woman's freedom to
make her own healthcare decisions for
the president it's going to be all about
the personal connection who he feels
comfortable with in the moment so you're
saying he's gonna pick the man so as REM
once put at the end of the world as we
know it I've never seen a president
United States in effect make himself a
puppet of outside groups and choose from
a group of right-wing fringe ideologues
I frankly don't even think we should be
considering this nominee now none of
this rhetoric is surprising at all none
of its new one of the most notable smear
campaigns from the Democrats took place
in the 1980s during Ronald Reagan's
nomination of an originalist an
intellectual to the Supreme Court his
name was judge Robert Bork and by the
way he was never confirmed to the US
Supreme Court in large part because of
what was lying and fear-mongering and
just frankly smearing by people like
Senator Ted Chappaquiddick Kennedy you
may remember this take a look Robert
Bork's America is a land of which women
would be forced into back-alley
abortions blacks would sit at segregated
lunch counters rogue police could break
down citizen's doors and midnight raids
schoolchildren could not be taught about
evolution writers and artists would be
censored at the whim of government but
the Democrats did too Judge Robert Bork
was so egregious that it inspired a new
term called boar King and years later
boar King was in full play during the
confirmation hearings of now Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas by the way
I think one of the best justices we've
ever had on the court in our lifetime
back in 1991 Democrats rolled out a
former colleague and need a hill to make
allegations against him and it became so
nasty that Justice Thomas called it a
quote high-tech lynching watch this this
is a circus it's a national disgrace and
from my standpoint as a black American
as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the u.s. US Senate rather than hung from
a tree it's already begun right now by
Democrats to judge Kavanagh and to his
family as we speak that it didn't matter
who the president would have picked and
by the way if you ever want to read a
fantastic book
my grandfather's son it was written by
Justice Thomas amazing book an amazing
family an amazing life story and as we
speak you have this all-out effort to
Bork judge Cavanaugh it's in full swing
most Democrats will never accept that
they lost the election and that
President Trump is appointing somebody
who believes in fidelity to the
Constitution that believes in separation
of powers that interprets US law based
on the clear and written intent of our
founders and the clear and written law
as written by a separate branch of
government in other words the
legislative branch and values in daily
rights in our Constitution above all
allows someone that believes in these
very important constitutional principles
separation of powers co-equal branches
of government instead the left what do
they want they prefer Hilary's choices
judicial activists people that will
legislate from the bench people that
would even go as far as not not rely in
the Constitution but even use
international law to justify their
activist decisions superseding our own
constitution activist justices often
creating law instead of interpreting the
law interpreting the Constitution and
given that Democratic friends well
perfect cover for having to vote on many
controversial left-wing in issues that
they would never get at the ballot box
or legislatively now because judge
Kavanagh is not Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg or justice Sotomayor yet ruddy
hold tight buckle up Democrats are about
to tell you as they have been saying for
12 days now the sky is going to fall the
world as you know it is going to end and
they want you to believe they will lie
to you they want you to believe judge
Cavanaugh is going to lead okay just
like Republicans the dirty air dirty
water the rise of let's see racism
sexism misogyny is Ahmet cetera et
cetera and by the way that America will
cease to exist as we know it now my
advice to the American people they are
long going to lie to you that's what
they do you have to listen to your own
heart and mind through your own research
we will be presenting as much
information as we can on this program
the Democrats are trying to lie for
political gain and as always an
originalist a constitutionalist an
appointment such as this to the Supreme
Court strengthens the foundation of this
country the original intent of our
founders and of our framers the world is
not coming to an end just as it did not
come to an end after these successful
appointment of Clarence Thomas Sam Alito
or Neil Gorsuch we will have much more
analysis coming up in the show now let's
turn to the deep state I want to tell
you about two breaking stories that will
blow your mind
Trump aiding former FBI lawyer Lisa
Paige has officially been sappy
she is going to appear before a
closed-door congressional hearing this
Wednesday and by the way after days
illegal hedging lisa pages one-time
boyfriend the disgraced trump aiding FBI
agent Peter struck he will testify you
will get to see it before the House
Judiciary and oversight committees that
will be right live right here on Fox
this Thursday it will be public it will
be explosive and of course struck is the
high ranking agent at the heart of this
effort to clear Hillary Clinton of all
charges
all while opening up a subsequent
witch-hunt into Donald Trump and
so-called Trump Russia collusion so now
this Thursday also struck will be forced
to answer for his extreme bias and more
importantly be forced to answer
questions about the culture the FBI what
role political prejudice played in the
FBI's decisions in 2016 and beyond by
the way one other note the show was
hitting the road later this week to
cover all the breaking developments with
the president's trip to Brussels and
London and then of course Helsinki and
of course the important negotiations
with NATO and meeting Vladimir Putin
we'll get to all of that